This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Cities like living things evolve slowly over time. Buildings and structures get added and renovated and removed. And in this process, there are bits and pieces that get left behind. Little bestages. Humans have tailbones, but no tails. Whales have pelvic bones, but no legs. Whales have pelvic bones but no legs. And cities have stairs that lead to nowhere.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。城市就像生物一样，随着时间的推移缓慢进化。建筑物和结构被添加、翻新和拆除。在这个过程中，总有一些碎片被遗留下来。就像小小的痕迹。人类有尾骨，但没有尾巴。鲸鱼有骨盆，但没有腿。鲸鱼有骨盆，但没有腿。而城市里有通往虚无的楼梯。
Telephone poles without wiring. And pipes that carry nothing at all. That's producer Avery Trufflement. Most of the time, these architectural leftovers rust or crumble are get taken down. But other times, these vestiges are not removed and they remain in the urban organism. And sometimes, even though they no longer serve any discernible purpose whatsoever, they are actually maintained. They get cleaned and polished and repaired and repainted just because they're there. These architectural leftovers first caught the attention of an artist in Japan named
没有电线的电线杆。还有什么都不承载的管道。这是制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。大多数时候，这些建筑遗留物会生锈、崩塌或被拆除。但有时，这些痕迹并没有被移除，而是留在了城市有机体中。有时，尽管它们不再有任何明显的用途，但实际上它们得到了维护。它们被清洁、打磨、修理和重新粉刷，仅仅因为它们就在那里。这些建筑遗留物最初引起了一位日本艺术家的注意，他叫
Akasa Gawa Ganpei. This was in 1972. One day he was on his lunch break with some friends. And as they were walking to lunch, they came across this staircase that went up and then back down. But there was no door at the top. He basically just walked up and then walked back down. And there was a piece of the railing that had been recently fixed.
赤濑川原平。那是1972年。一天，他正和朋友们吃午饭。当他们走去吃午饭时，偶然发现了一段楼梯，向上走然后又向下走。但楼梯顶端并没有门。他基本上就是走上去又走下来。而且栏杆上有一块地方最近刚被修补过。
Something clicked with him when he saw that. That is Mat Fargo. He's translated to Casagawa's work into English. A Casagawa himself doesn't speak English. And he's up there in the years and he's not currently doing any interviews. But his passion for these city vestiges spread to Mat Fargo. It's very rare for one. There's not a lot of facets of our life these days that are allowed to be completely purposeless.
当他看到那一幕时，某种东西触动了他。那是马特·法戈。他将赤濑川的作品翻译成了英文。赤濑川本人不会说英语。他年纪大了，目前不接受任何采访。但他对这些城市痕迹的热情感染了马特·法戈。这非常罕见。如今我们生活中没有多少东西是被允许完全没有用途的。
Acosta Gowas saw these urban leftovers as artistic byproducts of the city. He photographed all the things he could find that were both vestigial and maintained. He began publishing his findings in a magazine column, accompanied by musings about each object. So, for example, this is what Akasagawa wrote about those stairs to nowhere. Everything in our capitalist society has to have a purpose. So where does that leave this particular staircase? Could you even call it a staircase when all it did was let you peep into a window?
赤濑川将这些城市遗留物视为城市的艺术副产品。他拍摄了他能找到的所有既是痕迹又得到维护的东西。他开始在杂志专栏中发表他的发现，并附上对每件物体的思考。例如，这就是赤濑川关于那些通往虚无的楼梯所写的内容。我们资本主义社会中的一切都必须有目的。那么，这个特殊的楼梯又算什么呢？当它唯一的作用就是让你窥视窗户时，你还能称它为楼梯吗？
Of course you can't. You can only call it a staircase when all it did was let you peep into a window? Of course you can't. You can only call it art. A work of art shaped like a staircase. People began to send a Kasegawa pictures of similar architectural leftovers that they found. And in his column, a Kasegawa would evaluate their submissions on two criteria. One, were they truly, completely useless, and two, had they been recently maintained.
当然不能。你只能称它为艺术。一件形状像楼梯的艺术品。人们开始给赤濑川寄去他们发现的类似建筑遗留物的照片。在他的专栏中，赤濑川会根据两个标准来评估他们的投稿。第一，它们是否真的完全没用；第二，它们是否最近得到了维护。
In 1985, Acosta Gawa published a book of these collected photographs and writings, which Matt Fargo translated into English for the first time in 2009. And of course, now Matt finds these things everywhere, and they've changed the way he sees his surroundings. Architecture is constantly changing and being amended. So it is fun to think about, how do we end up where we are right now, and the warp and wof of how it formed over years. It's not a static, immutable thing. The changing nature of the city was especially clear to Akasagawa as a Japanese artist.
1985年，赤濑川出版了一本收集这些照片和文章的书，马特·法戈在2009年首次将其翻译成英文。当然，现在马特到处都能看到这些东西，它们改变了他看待周围环境的方式。建筑在不断变化和修正。所以思考我们是如何走到今天这一步，以及它多年来形成的经纬，是很有趣的。它不是一个静态、不可改变的东西。城市不断变化的本质对作为日本艺术家的赤濑川来说尤为清晰。
Japan's rapid reorganization after World War II created a lot of these city vestiges. A gossagawa coined a term for these kinds of urban leftovers, those that are, again, both totally purposeless and regularly maintained. He called them Thomason's. It comes from Gary Thomason, who was a baseball player, an American baseball player, and a really good one. Gary Thomason played for the LA Dodgers, the New York Yankees, and the San Francisco Giants.
二战后日本的快速重组创造了许多这样的城市痕迹。赤濑川为这类城市遗留物创造了一个术语，即那些既完全没用又定期维护的东西。他称它们为“托马森”。这个名字来自加里·托马森，他是一名棒球运动员，一名美国棒球运动员，而且非常出色。加里·托马森曾效力于洛杉矶道奇队、纽约洋基队和旧金山巨人队。
And then he was snatched up by another team, also called the Giants. The Yomiyori Giants, which is like the Yankees of Japan, they have all the money and they win a lot of titles. And also, incidentally, Akasegao's favorite baseball team, located in Tokyo. They hired him to come over and they paid him an exorbitant amount of money. But in this new country, on this new team, the great slugger Gary Thomason lost his stride. He got there and could not hit a Japanese pitcher for the life of him. He actually set the all-time strikeout record in Japan in 1981, and he remained in this
后来他被另一支也叫巨人队的球队挖走了。读卖巨人队，就像日本的洋基队一样，他们财力雄厚，赢得了许多冠军。顺便说一句，这也是赤濑川最喜欢的棒球球队，位于东京。他们雇佣了他，并支付给他一笔巨额薪水。但在新的国家，在新的球队里，这位伟大的强打者加里·托马森失去了节奏。他到了那里，却怎么也打不到日本投手的球。他实际上在1981年创下了日本历史上的三振纪录，并且他一直处于这种
rut until his contract ran out the following year. So he basically ended up just sitting on the bench and collecting a lot of money. Miss after Miss Gary Thomas and gained the nickname, the human fan, you know, for swinging the bat around and only moving the air. And so this kind of useless player that was being physically maintained was a Kasega was foiled for these objects he was finding. After Matt translated a Kasega was original book, which by the way is entitled Hyper Art Thomason.
低谷中，直到第二年合同到期。所以他基本上最后只是坐在替补席上，拿着高薪。一次又一次的挥棒落空，加里·托马森得到了“人体电风扇”的绰号，你知道的，因为他挥动球棒却只打到了空气。所以这种被物质上供养着的无用球员，成了赤濑川发现这些物体的对照。在马特翻译了赤濑川的原著之后，顺便说一下，书名是《超艺术托马森》。
The American publishers wanted to get a conversation going state side. They collaborated with a team of artists and photographers to find Thomason's all around San Francisco, which is where the publisher was based at the time. It was partly its own project and it was partly to promote the book and the idea. Claire Light spearheaded this project and she and collaborator Alan Manolo took us on their own Thomas and Tour. You find them all of a city, I'm not showing to you, yeah, we'll go down four.
美国出版商想在美国国内引发讨论。他们与一个艺术家和摄影师团队合作，在旧金山各地寻找托马森，这也是出版商当时所在地。这既是一个独立的项目，也是为了推广这本书和这个理念。克莱尔·莱特领导了这个项目，她和合作者艾伦·马诺洛带我们进行了他们自己的“托马森之旅”。你在城市各处都能找到它们，我没在给你展示，是的，我们要去四楼。
Of all the Thomasans that Claire and Alan found in San Francisco, their favorite ones, sit poetically on a drawbridge right in front of AT&T Park. Home of the world champion San Francisco Giants. Alan's a big Giants fan. And outside the stadium on a drawbridge named after a former giant left-yodoole beyond a plaza named after former giant Louis Mays, he found some objects unovisually named after former giant Gary Thomas. There's two on one on each side. They look like little kind of robot century guards. So picture this. There's a drawbridge and on either side are these lifting arm gates.
在克莱尔和艾伦在旧金山找到的所有托马森中，他们最喜欢的一处诗意地坐落在AT&T球场前的一座吊桥上。那是世界冠军旧金山巨人队的主场。艾伦是巨人队的铁杆粉丝。在体育场外，在一座以巨人队前球员命名的吊桥上，在以巨人队前球员路易斯·梅斯命名的广场前，他发现了一些以巨人队前球员加里·托马森命名的物体。两边各有一个。它们看起来像某种机器人哨兵。想象一下：有一座吊桥，两边是升降臂闸门。
You know, like the barriers that lower at railroad crossings to keep the cars from moving forward. you know, like the barriers that lower at railroad crossings to keep the cars from moving forward. But next to these modern lifting arm gates are the old models, or what's left of them. Their arms were chopped off, but the base is still there. And this old useless base is still maintained. They actually took the trouble to move the damn thing, but they didn't remove it. And they had it painted before, so we could not figure out why it's still here. And it's painted like the same colors, the bridge black,
你知道，就像铁路道口降下的那种栅栏，防止汽车继续前进。但这些现代升降臂闸门旁边是旧型号，或者说是它们剩下的部分。它们的臂被砍掉了，但底座还在。而这个旧的、没用的底座仍然得到维护。他们实际上费心移动了那个该死的东西，但却没有把它拆除。而且它之前被粉刷过，所以我们无法弄清楚为什么它还在这里。它被漆成了和桥一样的颜色，黑色，
this kind of industrial black. And these Thomassons were some of the only indisputable examples that Claire and Alan found. There are plenty of things around the city that are just derelict. It's the maintenance that makes it a true Thomasson. Claire and Alan drove us to a loading dock by the San Francisco Marina and pointed out a staircase that led to nowhere. A classic Thomason.
这种工业黑。这些托马森是克莱尔和艾伦找到的仅有的几个无可争议的例子。城市里有很多东西只是被废弃了。正是维护才使它成为真正的托马森。克莱尔和艾伦开车带我们去了旧金山码头附近的一个装卸平台，指出了一个通往虚无的楼梯。一个经典的托马森。
Or so it seemed. Upon closer look, we weren't so certain. I think that one is more of the Thomason. I don't think it has been repainted because if you look at the bottom, the pink fades into the rust. But if you look at the other railings over there, they're all roasted. So that's where they're going. Let's take a closer look. The four of us huddled around this railing and tried to figure out if the rust was painted
或者看起来是这样。仔细一看，我们就不那么确定了。我认为那个更像是托马森。我不认为它被重新粉刷过，因为如果你看底部，粉红色融入了锈迹中。但如果你看那边的其他栏杆，它们都生锈了。所以这就是它们要去的地方。让我们仔细看看。我们四个人围着这个栏杆，试图弄清楚锈迹是否被
over, which would mean that it was a Thomason, or the paint was rusted over, which would make it not a Thomason. It looks like it was freshly painted, but then we're figuring it wasn't and that it just hasn't been used and so that's why it doesn't look like it doesn't have nicks or cuts on it. This discourse is part of the fun of Thomasons. Anyone can just look at broken-down city parts,
覆盖了，如果是的话，那它就是一个托马森；或者油漆是否生锈了，那它就不是托马森。它看起来像是刚刷过漆，但我们觉得不是，它只是没被使用过，所以看起来没有划痕或缺口。这种讨论是托马森乐趣的一部分。任何人都可以看看破旧的城市部件，
but it takes active examination and attention to assess if this object is truly useless and has been cared for. This detailed look and debate is what at Casagawa was encouraging in his writings and publications. And so we thought we would imitate that with our website. Claire teamed up with Matt Fargo, the translator, to create a blog where people could offer up their own
但需要积极的观察和关注才能评估这个物体是否真的没用且得到了照料。这种细致的观察和辩论正是赤濑川在他的著作和出版物中所鼓励的。所以我们想用我们的网站来模仿这一点。克莱尔与译者马特·法戈合作创建了一个博客，人们可以在上面提供他们自己的
potential Thomassons for analysis and debate. And so people were actually using it and sending in their Thomassons from all over. Like in Acasagawa's original magazine column, there are submissions. And there's commentary as to whether or not they met the definition of a Thomason. And we got a lot of really beautiful pictures. That's Translitter Matfargo again. And then one day they got a submission that was definitely not a Thomason. Or maybe it was the truest Thomason of them all. One day we got one that was just a big picture of a middle finger and it said thank you for making my family forever famous or something like that and it was
潜在托马森供分析和辩论。人们确实在使用它，并从各地寄来他们的托马森。就像赤濑川最初的杂志专栏一样，有投稿。还有关于它们是否符合托马森定义的评论。我们收到了很多非常漂亮的照片。那是译者马特·法戈再次发言。然后有一天，他们收到了一份投稿，那绝对不是托马森。或者也许它是所有托马森中最真实的一个。有一天我们收到了一张照片，上面就是一个巨大的中指，写着“谢谢你们让我家人永远出名”之类的，那是
from Gary Thomason's daughter. That middle finger was a pretty clear sign. The Thomason family is not pleased, if indeed that is actually Gary Thomason's daughter who submitted it. But either way the family declined to comment for this story. Which brings us to another debate beyond whether or not something is of Thomason. Is it fair to call these things Thomason's at all? Gary Thomason was a remarkable baseball player for a long time, and just being a professional baseball player in and of itself is amazing. Hitting a baseball and going 90 miles per hour is about the hardest thing to do in professional
来自加里·托马森的女儿。那个中指是一个非常明确的信号。托马森一家并不高兴，如果确实是加里·托马森的女儿提交的话。但无论如何，托马森一家拒绝就这个故事发表评论。这引出了另一个辩论，除了某物是否是托马森之外。称这些东西为“托马森”公平吗？加里·托马森长期以来是一位出色的棒球运动员，仅仅作为一名职业棒球运动员本身就很了不起。以每小时90英里的速度击打棒球是职业
sports. If you are fantastic at it, you'll fail 70% of the time. Combine that with Thomason getting on in years, the stress of living abroad, and any number of other things that could have been going on in his life at the time. It's totally understandable that he wasn't the slugger that he was for the San Francisco Giants. And a cassega when you're that, he followed baseball. He was a fan of the Yomu Yuri Giants.
运动中最难的事情之一。如果你在这方面非常出色，你也会有70%的时间失败。再加上托马森年纪渐长，在国外生活的压力，以及当时他生活中可能发生的任何其他事情。完全可以理解他为什么不再是他在旧金山巨人队时的那个强打者了。而赤濑川，他关注棒球。他是读卖巨人队的球迷。
He was a fan of Gary Thomson. It was, a cassega was big fear when we told him we wanted to publish the book. He's like, I don't know about publishing it in English because it might be really embarrassing for the Thomason family and don't want to hurt any feelings. He's a sweet man. Matt himself was pretty nervous about the Thomason family's reaction. I can't imagine what he would say or, yeah just hope he knows that uh nothing but love for him and that that Acosta Ga was really really nervous about that. But not so nervous that Acosta Ga Ga would not publish the book. And unfortunately the name Thomasin works well. It fits. It's catchy. And
他是加里·托马森的球迷。当我们告诉他我们想出版这本书时，这是赤濑川最大的担忧。他说：“我不知道用英语出版它是否合适，因为它可能会让托马森一家感到非常尴尬，我不想伤害任何人的感情。”他是个温柔的人。马特本人对托马森一家的反应也感到非常紧张。我无法想象他会说什么，或者，是的，只希望他知道，对他只有爱，而赤濑川对此真的非常非常紧张。但并没有紧张到让赤濑川不出版这本书。不幸的是，“托马森”这个名字效果很好。它很贴切。它朗朗上口。而且
maybe it's kind of mean. In fact when I first heard about Thomas' sense I thought it was really mean. But then I tried to remember all the baseball players I could from the 1970s and I came up with something like four names. And now because of a Kasegawa, Gary Thomas' has transcended even Pete Rose and Reggie Jackson and joined the immortal ranks of the eponym, Cartigan, Liatar, Guillotine, Sandwich, Silhouette, and Plymsol. However, hurtful, the useless title might be, the legacy of a Casa Gawa's Thomason, one could argue, is ultimately a positive one. Thomasons are delightful to find.
也许这有点刻薄。事实上，当我第一次听说托马森时，我觉得这真的很刻薄。但后来我试着回忆我能想到的所有1970年代的棒球运动员，我只想到了四个名字。现在，因为赤濑川，加里·托马森甚至超越了皮特·罗斯和雷吉·杰克逊，加入了以人名命名的不朽行列，如开襟羊毛衫、平底船、断头台、三明治、剪影和普利姆斯鞋。然而，无论这个无用的头衔多么伤人，赤濑川的托马森的遗产，可以说，最终是积极的。托马森是令人愉快的发现。
They have inspired artists, translators, performers, and urban explorers around the world. Thomasons are treasures, waiting to be discovered and analyzed. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in Plus, if you need to get a gift for the Urban Design enthusiast who has everything, I'm thinking a Gary Thomas and baseball card would be perfect. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Truffle Men With Sam Green's Fan Katie Mingle And Me Roman Mars We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and produced are the offices of Arksign, the Reggie Jackson of Architecture firms in beautiful downtown Oakland,
它们激励了世界各地的艺术家、译者、表演者和城市探索者。托马森是等待被发现和分析的宝藏。另外，如果你需要为拥有一切的城市设计爱好者挑选礼物，我想加里·托马森的棒球卡会很完美。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，山姆·格林、凯蒂·明格和我罗曼·马斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，制作地点位于美丽的奥克兰市中心，建筑界的雷吉·杰克逊——Arksign事务所，
California. You can keep up with all the goings on at 99pi on Twitter, Facebook, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify if you say hi, we usually say hi back. And if you ever need a place to crash, you can always hang out at our place at 99pi.org. Radio TIPI from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州。你可以在Twitter、Facebook、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上关注99pi的所有动态，如果你打个招呼，我们通常会回应。如果你需要一个落脚的地方，你随时可以在99pi.org上闲逛。来自PRX的Radio TIPI。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。